[Music]
good evening welcome to Washington I'm
Bret Baier President Trump says he
deserves an A+ for his accomplishments
as president and if he were to be
impeached the economy would have a
failing grade the comments in an
interview with Fox News come amid
increasing talk of possible legal and
political problems for the president
following convictions for two of his
former associates but it also comes as a
tense exchange with dueling statements
today erupted between the president and
his attorney general chief White House
correspondent John Roberts starts us off
tonight
from the North Lawn could even jump
bracket evening to you the one personal
quality the president Trump appears to
value above all else is loyalty tonight
we learned that now two people who were
very close very loyal to the president
have chosen their own well-being over
his in an exclusive interview aired on
Fox and Friends today President Trump
insisted he did nothing wrong in hush
money paid to two women and trashed his
former attorney Michael Cohen for
flipping on him
it almost sought to be outlawed it's not
fair if somebody defrauded a bank and
he's going to get ten years in jail or
20 years in jail but if you can say
something bad about Donald Trump and
you'll go down to two years or three
years which is the deal he made in all
fairness to him most people are going to
do that sources tell Fox News it wasn't
just Cohen who testified about President
Trump prosecutors granted immunity to
American media CEO David pecker
to learn about his involvement in
payments to Karen McDougal and stormy
Daniels and what role if any president
Trump had in it with talks whirling in
Washington about possible impeachment
the president warned it would risk the
economic gains of the last 22 months if
I ever got a piece I think the market
would crash I think everybody would be
very poor in an interview with Sky News
Rudy Giuliani went even further about
the fallout from an impeachment he had
only impeach him for political reasons
and the American people would revolt
against that according to Harvard Law
Professor Alan Dershowitz there is
nothing to impeach the president for
candidate Trump could have announced I'm
funding my own campaign
putting a billion of my dollars into the
campaign and I'm paying a hundred
million of them to women who have
accused me falsely
etc that would not be a violation of any
campaign law as long as he reported it
Democrats left on the Cohen plea and
mana Ford conviction making the case
that President Trump has done nothing to
fulfill his pledge to drain the
Washington swamp he has not cleaned the
swamp he has made it more wretched and
more fetid with the mana Ford and Cohen
wins under his belt special counsel
Robert Muller has new wind in his sails
causing President Trump to again lash
out at his Attorney General Jeff
Sessions for weak leadership
I put an attorney general that never
took control of the Justice Department
Jeff Sessions never took control of the
Justice Department and it's a sort of an
incredible thing sessions who was about
to go to the White House for a meeting
with the president felt compelled to put
out a statement saying quote I took
control of the Department of Justice the
day I was sworn in but the president
also took another swing at sessions for
recusing himself from the Russia
investigation he took the job and then
he said I'm going to recuse myself I
said what kind of a man is this that
prompted sessions to respond in a
statement quote while I am Attorney
General the actions of the Department of
Justice will not be improperly
influenced by political considerations
president Trump has given no indication
that he is going to fire Jeff Sessions
but some prominent Republicans are now
suggesting that after the midterm
elections may be sessions should step
down
Brett Warren all this with the panel
John Roberts live in the North Lawn John
thanks